hey folks if you'd like to support me or
this channel move university in creating
more video tutorials then please
consider making a financial contribution
on my website movie universe be calm
thanks and enjoy the video okay so try
acyl glycerol or triglycerides what are
those well in one word
they are fats that's that's the short
answer the more specific answer is that
triacylglycerols
or triglycerides are three fatty acids
connected to a glycerol backbone
glycerol backbone by ester linkages so
how does that look well okay so here
I've drawn this three carbon molecule
and this molecule is glycerol so this
three carbon molecule here we've got 1 2
3 carbons that is glycerol so let's draw
a little function as the backbone for
this overall structure that we're going
to draw and we're gonna take glycerol
and three fatty acids which I've drawn
here I don't know why I put that in that
color okay so three fatty acids that are
drawn here and of course the R groups
are labeled as one they're labeled as
one two and three because they could be
different they don't have to be but they
can be now what's going to happen is
that we can imagine a dehydration
synthesis so we're gonna basically going
to take this Oh H we're going to take
this H that's h2o there and then here
the same thing and then here the same
thing we're going to take those and
we're going to remove those as three
waters so this will be a dehydration
synthesis here dehydration so this is
dehydration because we're losing water
and synthesis because we're making a
bond right we're making we're linking
the glycerol backbone to these three
fatty acids and we get this molecule
here and so these linkages here labeled
in pink are the ester linkages right as
it actually gets there
there and there I all three of those are
ester linkages and a tester if you
aren't already familiar with it is when
you have an R group bound to a carbonyl
that's bound to an O R group and of
course those R groups can be just any
hydrocarbon chain and they can be the
same they could be different this is
basically an ester functional group and
so here we've got the basically these
three fatty acids that are linked to be
an ester linkage to this glycerol
backbone so this molecule here is a tri
a so glycerol okay or TIG or a
triglyceride
tgd now both of those terms mean the
same thing but let's break down the name
try a soul glycerol try acyl tri means
three acyl refers to this group here an
acyl group is basically just a group
that has an R group bound to a carbonyl
and the that sort of group there if we
cut that off if we link that to anything
that is called an acyl group so we have
a tri acyl group is there's 1 2 3 a so
groups and they're linked to a glycerol
backbone ok the common name is
triglycerides that is really broken down
in the same way that's right a so
glycerols is but the same thing now
those three those 3 fatty acids that are
attached as acyl groups they can be
saturated fatty acids or unsaturated
fatty acids we talked a little bit about
this in the fatty acid video about how
fats that contain saturated fatty acids
will be solid right and fats that
contain a higher concentration
unsaturated fatty acids will be liquids
so things like lard or animal fat will
be solid liquid that'll be things like
oils right ok and this is of course
provided at room temperature right ok so
now that we know the structure of a
trace of what's right or at right or
trace of glycerol or triglyceride
what are their what's their purpose was
their function well their main main
function that a lot of people are aware
of is fuel storage they store energy and
that should make sense because we've got
these these acyl groups are coming from
fatty acids and fatty acids we know can
can be broken down for energy so if
they're this is their storage form this
is when they're not being used for
energy so this is a mechanism of you'll
there or suti store fuel the other thing
that tray greggers loads are important
for is for insulation we'll talk about
both of these functions in more detail
now okay so if we think about energy
storage
or energy source fats triglycerides are
a super efficient energy storage form
because because we know that fatty acids
are highly highly reduced molecules
right they're electron rich not
something we talked about in a previous
video they're highly reduced and so
they're highly efficient in the amount
of energy there really dense in the
amount of energy they have right and so
we take these fatty acids and we store
them in triglycerides that's a very very
efficient storage what we're packing a
lot of energy into in one location one
in one structure now fatty acids if
they're roaming freely right if we have
free fatty acids they wouldn't mess with
pH levels well because they're acidic
right fatty acids are acids so we don't
want fatty acids to be roaming freely
roaming freely
would they mess up with the pH levels we
don't want that so triglycerides are
basically the solution to that problem
right because we don't want our pH
levels to be altered in any way because
even the slightest change in a pH in our
body could be detrimental to proteins
and could really lead to death so
triglycerides are the solution to that
problem when we have fatty acids if we
have an excess of them we can store them
in these triglycerides and then the the
fatty acids you see here um
in this structure in the triglyceride
structure since these fatty acids are no
longer you know in their in their either
acid form or carboxylate form they are
stored in the structure they'll no
longer alter pH levels now
triglycerides are stored in these things
called adipose cells adipose cells and
they're specifically called adipocytes
adipocytes so I've kind of drawn that
over here and I'll get to that diagram
in just a second
they contain these things called fat
droplets or fat reservoirs and that's
what I've drawn here in those in that
little brownish yellow color here so
these are fat droplets or fat reservoirs
and these things actually will get
bigger as the amount triglycerides grows
right so here we've got this fat
reservoir we'll call it fat reservoir a
and going to be B has many more
triglycerides in it it's just sort of
grown or swollen up so these get bigger
or larger with more triglycerides now
triglycerides are also another another
in detail about them is that
triglycerides are hydrophobic and
anhydrous now you might think those two
words mean the same thing
hydrophobic just means water fearing
right so doesn't like to hang out with
water but that leads into this idea of
it being anhydrous not only does it not
like water it just does not need water
to to exist like it could is so is so
hydrophobic that it kind of just wants
to stay stay away from water it doesn't
need to be dissolved in water and it's
in these fat reservoirs and this is
actually really important this
contributes to the efficiency of the
storage form because there's this
benefit over over glycogen right because
glycogen is also a storage form of
energy right that's just a bunch of
glucose is linked together in alpha one
four linkages but because triglycerides
are hydrophobic and hydrous a don't need
to be dissolved in water they don't have
to be hydrated in the way that glycogen
does it's like a gym being polar it
needs to be hydrated it is hydrous so
triglycerides don't have to carry
the extra weight of water so if they're
not hydrated they they don't basically
the reason why this is beneficial is
that if we didn't have triglycerides we
only could store energy in the form of
glycogen we would need a lot of water to
hydrate that glycogen whoo and water is
pretty heavy I mean if you imagine that
for every bit of like assume that we
have to have tons of water added on to
it
we would weigh so much and that would be
tough for us as humans or any other
animals to to carry that extra weight of
that water so triglycerides are part of
the solution to that problem right they
can they allow us to carry a lot of
stored energy without hydrating it and
it's not heavy for us to carry it can
eventually be heavy but I won't really
get into that so and uh okay so so now
once we have these triglycerides in the
storage form in fats right let's say
someone wants to sue or some some person
wants to lose some weight they or even
if they don't wanna lose weight maybe if
someone's fasting the point is that
there are times where we can take these
these these stored fatty acids that are
stored in these triglycerides and we can
mobilize them for energy right we could
freeze them up so there are enzymes
called lipases lipases lipases are the
enzymes that free up fatty acids during
fasting right during during fasting or
during long term use for energy so when
you're fasting your body is tapping on
fats for energy so or basically that's
fasting you can imagine is a long-term
use of energy or if you're running like
a like some sort of distance race right
your body is tapping on a long-term
energy source and that would be fats so
this is this is particularly important
for some some animals that have extended
periods of activity I think one example
that I read about was like birds that
that fly south for the winter
right so they fly based on season that's
a fly for a very long time
right so during that time they're going
to be tapping on fats for energy okay
cool
so that that hopefully wraps up the
energy storage idea a little bit now the
next thing I want to talk about is
insulation so a lot of adipose tissue is
located specifically beneath the skin
okay so beneath the skin and it it helps
insulate insulate basically just means
to help prevent heat loss right helps
contain that heat so it's important in
keeping us and other animals warm right
not warms keep helps keeps helps keep us
warm so now this is not super important
for us as humans it is important in some
cases but it's not super important for
humans because we have we have homes
that we could and shelters right and we
have clothes so we have clothes that can
keep us warm now I understand that not
everyone has a home not everyone has
clothes but generally speaking a human
understands the idea of clothes and
homes and and we we can use clothes to
keep us warm we could use our homes to
help us stay stay warm
we also even have central heating units
that that can help you this one we know
how to make fires things like that so
for humans insulation is not the most
essential function right but this is
especially important for animals like
polar bears right because polar bears
live in very very cold climates right
and they do have fur that help helps
keep them warm but when they're
hibernating even if they're um even if
they're in a cave that's more you know
that's helping you know reduce the
windchill factor they still need to stay
warm and so especially when they're
hibernating they're not really moving
around to keep themselves warm so they
it's having having that layers of fat to
to help keep keep the heat inside of
them especially during hibernation is
essential for them so I hope that video
was helpful in understanding
triglycerides their structure and their
functions thank you for watching yo if
you found that video helpful don't
forget to Like comment subscribe for
more content and if you know anybody who
might find the video is helpful then
please
with them Thanks happy studying